>>> AS ELON MUSK IS UNDER THE
MICROSCOPE FOR HIS UNPREDICTABLE
BEHAVIOR FOR THE NEW CEO OF
TWITTER, HE'S FACING A COMPLAINT
FROM EIGHT FORMER EMPLOYEES OF
ANOTHER COMPANY, THAT BEING
SPACEX.
LAST WEEK THEY FILED WITH THE
NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS BOARD
ALLEGING THAT WE FIRED SIMPLY
FOR CRITICIZING SOME OF MUSK'S
COMMENTS.
THE FORMER EMPLOYEES SAY THEY
PUT TOGETHER AN OPEN LETTER TO
SPACEX MANAGEMENT CALLING ON THE
COMPANY TO PUBLICLY CONDEMN
MUSK'S BEHAVIOR ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WHERE HE HAS MADE AT TIMES
SEXIST COMMENTS, ALSO MADE LIGHT
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS
AGAINST HIM.
THAT WAS SIGNED BY MANY
EMPLOYEES, MANY DID SO
ANONYMOUSLY.
JOINING ME NOW IS ONE OF THE
EMPLOYEES WHO WAS LET GO.
HAS NOT BEEN ANONYMOUS IS GOING
VERY PUBLIC WITH HER STORY, PAGE
HOLLAND THIELEN.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> SO FIRST FOR THE SAKE OF OUR
VIEWERS, EXPLAIN WHAT EXACTLY
ABOUT MUSK'S BEHAVIOR AND
COMMENTS LED YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO WRITE THIS LETTER?
>> SO, THERE IS A LONG HISTORY
OF POOR HANDLING OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AT SPACEX.
I WAS THERE FOR A LITTLE OVER
FOUR AND A QUARTER YEARS AND I
SPENT A LOT OF TIME TALKING TO
MY PEERS AND COLLEAGUES AND WHAT
THINK EXPERIENCED AND WHAT I
EXPERIENCED MYSELF.
IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT UNTIL THE
BEH
BEHAVE CHANGED FROM THE TOP
DOWN, THINGS WOULDN'T IMPROVE.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
THERE AT THE COMPANY.
>> YEAH.
ULTIMATELY WE WERE TRYING TO
IMPROVE OUR OWN WORKING
CONDITIONS, HAVE A REASONABLE
RESPONSE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS THAT WERE ORN GOING.
VERY OFTEN MISHANDLED, SOMETIMES
SWEPT UNDER THE RUG.
THE POLICIES ARE VERY UNCLEAR.
THEY LEAN ON THEIR NOTE POLICY
WITHOUT DEFINING WHAT THAT
MEANS.
SO ULTIMATELY, AND MOSTLY OUR
LETTER WAS ATTEMPTING TO GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARITY ON THOSE
POLICIES AND ENSURE THEY'RE
APPLIED EQUALLY THROUGHOUT THE
COMPANY.
>> YOU REFERENCED WHAT YOU
NOTED, THE COMPANY HAS A QUOTE,
NO A-HOLE POLICY.
>> WON'T USE THE WORD ON THE
AIR.
BUT WHAT DOES THAT POLICY
ACTUALLY SAY?
AND HOW DO THE COMPANY RESPOND
TO YOUR COMPLAINT?
>> UM, IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT THE NO
A-HOLE POLICY ACTUALLY MEANS.
AND BY MY COMPLAINT, DO YOU MEAN
THE LETTER?
>> YES.
THE LETTER THAT YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES WROTE.
>> THEY ASKED US INITIALLY WHEN
THE LETTER WAS RELEASED THEY
ASKED US TO STOP SPREADING IT.
I STOPPED ENGAGING WITH IT BUT
IT HAD TAKEN ON ITS OWN MOMENTUM
AT THIS POINT.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY AFTER
THE LETTER RELEASE, A HANDFUL OF
US WERE CALLED INTO HR MEETINGS
AND PROMPTLY FIRED.
>> SO THEIR RESPONSE WAS TO SAY
STOP DISTRIBUTING THE LETTER FOR
SIGNATURES.
>> YES.
>> NO NINE WERE FIRED AND EIGHT
JOINED THE COMPLAINT YOU HAVE
GOING NOW.
ONLY TWO OF YOU HAVE SPEAKING
OUT PUBLICLY.
AND I WONDER WHY YOU'RE TAKING
THAT, IT MAKES YOU A TARGET AND
IDENTIFIES YOURSELF.
WHY ARE YOU TAKING THE STEP TO
GO PUBLIC WITH THIS?
>> ONE OF THE MORE LIGHT-HEARTED
I THINK REASONS I'VE GIVEN
PEOPLE IS I FEEL LIKE I INTO HE
HAD TO BE BRAVER THAN I WAS WHEN
I GOT FIRED BUT ORGANIZING IN
THE WORKPLACE AT SPACEX WAS
INITIALLY MY IDEA.
AND I FEEL LIKE I JUST NEED TO
STAND BY THAT.
I NEED LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT IT
IS OKAY TO DO THIS, IT IS LEGAL
TO DO THIS.
YOU HAVE RIGHTS.
AND WHAT WE DID WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND I STILL THINK
THAT IS THE CASE.
I STILL THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
I STILL THINK IT WAS NECESSARY.
JUST BECAUSE THINGS DIDN'T
CHANGE RIGHT AWAY DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THERE IS NOT CHANGE COMING.
AND I WANT PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR THIS.
AND IF I FEEL LIKE I CAN'T ASK
PEOPLE TO STAND UP AND SPEAK IF
I WON'T SHOW MY FACE AND STAND
UP AND SPEAK MYSELF.
SO THAT IS WHY I'M HERE.
>> CREDIT TO YOU FOR TAKING THAT
STEP AND TAKING THAT RISK.
SO THE COMPLAINT NOW, THAT IS
BEFORE THE NATIONAL LABOR RIGHTS
BOARD AND THE BOARD WILL NOW
INVESTIGATE, WE UNDERSTAND IT
TAKES 14 WEEKS OR SO THREE
MONTHS AND THEN DECIDE.
WHAT WOULD BE AN IDEAL OUTCOME
FROM THIS PROCESS FOR YOU?
>> UM, I JUST WANT -- I JUST
WANT ACCOUNTABILITY, I WANT
JUSTICE FOR THOSE OF US WHO WERE
FIRED BECAUSE IT WAS WRONG.
I WANT THE PEOPLE WHO WERE LEFT
BEHIND TO KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE
TO LIVE LIKE THIS.
THERE IS SAY LOT OF FEAR BEING
SPREAD IN OUR WAKE SO I WANT
CHANGE AND I WANT ACCOUNTABILITY
AND I WANT JUSTICE.
>> DO YOU WANT YOUR JOB BACK?
>> I WOULD BE WILLING TO DO WHAT
THE NLRB IS ABLE TO DO WITH
THIS.
>> UNDERSTOOD.
WELL, LISTEN, WE WISH YOU THE
BEST OF LUCK.
IT IS NO EASY THING TO DO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING NOW, GIVEN THE
PUBLIC SPOTLIGHT AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME AND TELLING MY STORY.
>> GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
WE DID REACH OUT TO SPACEX FOR
COMMENT AND WE DID NOT HEAR
BACK.